so people often ask me do you believe in
God
which I don't I don't like that question
first of all it's an attempt to - it's
an attempt to box me in in a sense and
the reason that it's an attempt to box
me in is because the question is asked
so that I can be firmly placed on one
side of a - of a binary argument and and
the reason I don't like to answer it is
because a I don't like to be boxed in
and B because I don't know what the
person means by believe or God and they
think they know and the probability that
they construe belief and construe God
the same way I do is virtually zero so
it's a question that doesn't work for me
on multiple levels of analysis but but
strangely enough just as we were talking
I the answer to that question popped
into my head I act as if God exists now
you can decide for yourself whether that
means whether that I believe in him so
to speak but I act as if he exists so
that's a good enough answer for that
then with regards to these other issues
the divinity of Christ well I would say
the same problems with the question
formulation obtained what do you mean by
divine and also what do you mean by
Christ these are very very difficult
questions now I believe that for all
intents and purposes I believe that the
logos is divine insofar as we if by
divine you mean of ultimate value of
ultimate transcendent value yes it's
divine it's associated with death and
rebirth clearly because the logos
dismantles you and rebuilds you so
that's what happens when you make an
error when you make an error some part
of you has to go that's a sacrifice you
have to let it go sometimes it's a big
part of you it's it's sometimes it can
be such a big part of you that you
actually die
right instead of dying and being reborn
is there something more than merely
metaphorical about the idea of being of
dying and being reborn yes there is
because those are associated with
physiological transformations
how what's the ultimate extent of that
that's a good question
you know the question is what happens to
the world around you as you embark as
you increasingly embody the logos and
the answer to that is we don't know we
don't know what the ultimate level of
this now the hypothesis is a hypothesis
that extends to some degree to Buddha as
well the hypothesis is that there has
been one or two individuals who managed
that and that in their management of
that they transcended death itself well
then you might ask yourself well what do
you mean by transcended death well in
the case of Christ let's assume he was a
historical figure for the for the time
being which i think is the simplest
thing to assume I think there's
sufficient evidence to conclude that you
could conclude otherwise but I
personally I feel that there's
sufficient evidence to conclude that did
he is his resurrection real but his
spirit lives on that's certainly the
case in what sense do you mean spirit
just to qualify then how well let's
imagine that a spirit is a pattern of
being and we know that patterns can
exist in two powers can be transmitted
across multiple substrates right vinyl
electronic impulses air vibrations in
your ear neurological patterns dance
it's all the translation of what you
might describe as a spirit right it's
it's that pattern it's independent of
its material substrate
well Christ's spirit lives on it's a
it's had a massive effect across time
well is that an answer to the question
did his body resurrect I don't know I
don't know
it is the accounts aren't clear for one
thing what the accounts mean isn't clear
I don't know what happens to a person if
they
bring themselves completely into
alignment I've had intimations of what
that might mean we don't understand the
world very well we don't understand how
the world could be mastered if it was
mastered completely we don't know how an
individual might be able to manage that
we don't know what transformations that
might make possible